also hearing that Junior doctors
considering strike action from the start
of next year
um joining us now Pat McFadden for labor
high it's good to see you thanks for
joining us I mean you guys have
supported the government when it comes
to reducing the National Insurance
increase again so that's 36 billion
pounds over three years that will not be
in the pot there's not enough money to
go around to pay nurses is what the
government would say
well it's only a couple of years since
we were all clapping nurses and NHS
staff during the covert pandemic so it's
right that they get a decent pay rise no
uh you know it's important that that
happens
on the overall budgets uh we always
thought it was a bad idea to put a
National Insurance rise in place when
inflation was rising and people were
always struggling with the cost of
living crisis that didn't make sense to
us before and it doesn't know so that's
one element that we think shouldn't
proceed at this time as the National
Insurance rise yeah but you think that
nurses should get money doctors should
get money rail workers should get money
um everybody should get a pay Rise by a
potentially about inflation where's all
the money going to come from
you've got to look at these things uh in
their own not just measure by measure I
mean we could go through things about
how we would raise money but the key
thing that's driving instability right
now is the mini budget a couple of weeks
ago that's what's caused this material
risk to financial stability you were
discuss in a few moments ago that's
what's caused the spake in mortgage
rates that's going to hurt people we
wouldn't have done that and it's really
important now because it looks like
where the government's going to go is
having made the initial mistake they're
now going to Institute a series of cuts
and public services so that the users of
those public services will end up paying
the political price instead no you've
got to pause this and go back to that
mini budget a couple of weeks ago it is
clearly that that's triggered this
problem It's a UK specific problem it
has undermined The credibility of the UK
and what's really important now is that
the consequence of that isn't a whole
series of cuts and public services
brought it forward to the 31st of
October to address some of your those
very concerns but that would be an
appalling outcome what I'm concerned
about is that they will double down and
make the users of Public Services pay
the price for their political mistakes
that's not the way they should proceed
now having seen the chaos in financial
markets the better option would be to
revisit the budget that caused those
mistakes rather than cut some public
services to make up for them so how okay
I hear you so how are we going to find
60 billion quid there wasn't 60 billion
pounds in that mini budget
well it was 45 in it I think they did
you wouldn't need to find 60 billion
pounds if you Revisited the mini budget
itself it's the scale of that the idea
that they would then double down on it
and the disregard for The Economic
Institutions that Safeguard the UK's
economic credibility it's all those
things coming together so you change the
you reverse decision on the corporation
tax uh what else would you do
well there's a you know you can go
through it measure by measure
um the the one that we support and then
I say is the National Insurance rise but
the bottom line is we just wouldn't have
a non-start budget and it's not budget
that's caused the economic problem yeah
but we are where we are so how do you
fix it well if you want other taxation
measures uh we think you could get more
from the windfall tax for example uh
significantly more than they're planning
to we've announced that we would get rid
of non-dom status you'd have a better
balance overall I haven't come on here
to say that the government should never
borrow
governments do borrow governments around
the world are borrowing should they
borrow more than that this uh this
particular crisis we're seeing isn't
because a threshold of a pound more or a
billion pounds more on borrowing has
been reached it's an overall approach of
a big package of unfunded tax cuts
financed purely through borrowing and
then saying this is just the beginning
we're going to do more of this that's
what's caused the chaos and what's
really important now is that users of
Public Services don't pay the price I'm
not crying about what you're saying I
need a glass of water I'm sure Corey
will bring one for me in just a second
or two talk to me about what's happening
with the former Shadow Minister Sam
um Tammy this morning
um here's Terry forgive me um he's lost
his position and he's lost his
opportunity to be an MP at the next
election is that the right decision well
all MPS have to go through this process
of reselection I did it at the beginning
of the year it's essentially a vote of
confidence or otherwise then you buy a
local party
I do know Jazz Atwell a person who was
voted for last night is really popular
in ilford he'll be a great MP I'm
looking forward to working with them
that's part of our processes what was
the answer to that question I'm not sure
what you say are you saying it was the
right decision well it's a decision for
the party members in ilford yeah I know
but it's the right decision oh it's
their decision but what do you think of
the decision I think Jazz Atwell is a
great guy I think he's going to be a
great candidate he'd be a great MP if he
gets elected and I'm really looking
forward what about Sam
well
um you know this is a process that we
all have to go through I had to go
through my resurrection Sam's had to go
through his uh it wasn't he was standing
on a picket line he was supporting the
workers and now he's lost his job you
know who can who can see why the members
in ilford uh voted the way they did they
clearly thought Jazz Atwell would be a
better candidate next time as I say Jazz
up I was a good guy he'd be a great MP
and I'm looking forward to working with
it talk to me about Tom Watson um should
he get a period
uh well that's well above my peer grid
no no Nancy you're here because I can
put these questions to you I'm not
saying that you make the decision okay
well can you answer it
um I don't see why you shouldn't well we
know why some people say he shouldn't
because of what happened when there was
a string of Lies made about allegations
about senior people here at Westminster
including Lord Britain and his uh Lord
Britain's now Widow is furious by the
suggestion that he could potentially get
a period I'm sure when they're doing
these nominations and and considering
these things they take everything into
account in someone's long you know the
full Arc of the I understand that but
what do you think look I think if
someone's been Deputy leader of a you
know one of the major political parties
in the country It's Not Unusual that
they'd end up in the House of Lords at
the end of that time and it wouldn't be
offensive to those that have suffered as
a result of the allegations that were
made you know they'll
you know the people will everybody will
have that view and people obviously got
a right to their opinion about it
well I think a deputy leader of a major
political party ended up in the House of
Lords is is pretty normal it's happened
to plenty of his predecessors
um MPS are all back
um from today pmqs tomorrow we're going
to see your leader up against
um
the new prime minister how do you think
that's going to go well it's always it's
always interesting when you get a change
like that and I remember it uh back in
the days when I worked with Tony Blair
in number 10 and sometimes the leader of
the opposition would change and I think
it usually takes a while to to work out
the other person it's a bit of probing
and it takes a while so I don't think
you'll see exactly how it will go
tomorrow I would say give it give it a
month or two look at five or six of
these jokes then you'll know how old
okay try not to make me cry next time
you come in I really will
I'm so sorry about that thank you very
much indeed for joining us thanks a lot
as always